what's going on reject nation greg here
we got a
john and eleven hour here today to watch
the boys
episode one of season two just say us
off the bat subscribe
click that notification bell so you get
notified when our next reaction for
the boys is up here on the channel with
the way youtube works we can only allow
10 minutes worth of the footage from the
show to be included
so this is going to qualify as reaction
highlights full length reaction watch
along is where you sync up with the time
code for the boys will be available over
at our patreon page
speaking of which we cover a lot of tv
shows where at the same tier we have the
option for watch long and reaction
highlights included for many of shows
and those shows are supernatural doctor
who
joe joe's bizarre adventure the promised
neverland attack on titan
death note my hero academia code geass
hanahan full metal alchemist brotherhood
violet evergarden demon slayer and we
also got a weekly q a podcast and there
are many shows where we only do
watch alongs for them so guys really
appreciate if you show your support and
become a patron today last but not least
i do want to give a shout out to eric at
nerd chronic
who is like the main editor for the
movie trivia showdown has edited for us
in the past he's going to be editing the
highlights for us big love to that guy
check out his podcast forever podcaster
found let's get into
this
oh so early
oh snap okay
oh great translucent
murdered in cold blood cartel
diablo
[Applause]
so she is still part of the seven okay i
thought she would have been caught by
now
hey that's my shoulder hey that's my
shirt
it's my [ __ ] shoulder
look how exhausted he is yeah
see a plane this guy it was a reference
season one huh
did you snap the sim cards yes i am not
recognizing the sim card
okay and she's ugly now she has no
makeup on
yeah you um you look good too
you know uh i'm kind of tired
yeah mine i just said
are you stalking me on instagram no no
of course not get over yourself
you're [ __ ] at them awards and you're
taking public photos
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i'm sorry i am
butch oh you think this is fun
oh gosh i think water's supposed to
happen
[Laughter]
oh no you think water's supposed to be
fun
oh my god it's cold okay i know you
yeah you're wrong raven oh raven
it's eagle eagle the archer you're way
oh raven wink you bailed me out
because even heroes need a hand once in
a while
come on even if they don't remember your
damn name baby
needs a mother joy
[Music]
and why was madeleine stillwell's baby
found safe
in a yard 17.
baby's alive guys we get some compound v
we
we bring it to the new york times yeah
we burn vodka they were gonna use that
compound yeah
we could get some someone could help us
get it
and who might that be oh they don't know
they don't know lacroix sponsorship
my man so much sparkling water in this
episode
oh no oh drink it don't drink it
drink it homeland homelander
remember what she tasted like oh
no drink it oh you disappoint me
homeless
warming it up oh yeah you're my man
homeland
any residue
[Laughter]
i was uh
laser hurt it's blind spot right a
differently abled member of the seven
and then smart not an ethnic or female
or fingers crossed
to replace the teeth
hold on you can tell it's me
wow what do you mean i think he's blind
usually i'm the last one again is this
gonna be a racist thing
[Laughter]
what happens if oh no oh i don't know if
i
do this
oh my god
in no [ __ ] way do you decide who goes
in the seven
i decided oh man i thought homelander
was actually excited about having
are you gonna pay for that oh wow some
hero you are creating property damage
wow um do you want me to uh start or
chop or whatever floats your boat tiger
400 for that you can make so much more
money on only fans
you you you ew
i'd keep the arm right i'll just keep it
refrigerated
cool wow for an extra ground i'll let
you drop off my dick
oh come on do it where's the closest
yeah
what atm will give you a grand i've been
looking forward to meeting you deep
would you like a fresco
thank you and what are you a therapist
or something
mom no therapy's very destructive
actually scientology you could say i'm
his teacher
carol really helped me dee no thank you
help you get back into the seven
oh incentive a lot
more than anything for life
what it's a cult it's
scientology call annie
call annie they're praying that you do
that
good point now what you don't want to do
is tell them you
you [ __ ] called him no no i'm not i'm
not stupid okay
i don't know about that oh that was not
gonna make it i texted you
and then we met up but we're getting
some compound v they could be watching
us right [ __ ] now
you've been walking around for days like
you want to kick my ass
so do it already you are not a soldier
you're not a spy you're just a kid
that's so stereotypical no i don't
i lost my job i don't have a job so
maybe i can't be lady marvin
sure you can but i could be harry potter
you know john connor or or what's her
name from
the hunger games
[Music]
all right go you guys wish me luck oh
fyi not a real base i'm the new girl
wait what are you talking about oh she's
officially part of it
hi i'm in the seven oh my god replacing
translucent
god bless his soul ashley you're gonna
get
killed who delivered the good news
oh uh mr edgar the big guy
wonderful oh is that uh john carlo yeah
all right well mr edgar for real
hey it looks like it does look like
it's the [ __ ] spider [ __ ]
deputy director i know this might not be
the best time to ask but do you ever
hear about your family your daughter is
uh starting soccer i think
i've moved in with them thank you ma'am
thanks huey okay so give me that
appreciate you looking out you're my
best friend uh about
5 10 165. i've been trying to put this
puzzle together and there's a missing
piece and it's been driving me nuts and
i think you just handed it to me
wait what are you talking about why
wouldn't you share this with them
uh oh no ma'am your nose
oh my oh
wow what do you know
about frederick vaught
such the rising young star that in 39
hitler appointed him chief position at
dachau
oh great great background when
oppenheimer was flailing with the bomb
dr vaught already had practical
applications of compound b
tested in the field heroes like soldier
boy
killing germans by the dozen and he
became as wonder bred american
disney and edison
and you are not our most valuable asset
that would be our confidential formula
for compound v
which you man child that you are
released
don't know what you're talking about i
don't think i appreciate your tone
sir not much at all
there's got to be a reason why he's not
scared of him while you're
preening at the golden globes we are
busy
running around like maniacs trying to
clean up the mess you made
well i like him i know it's john carla's
good and everything
it's me what jesus you shouldn't be
calling me
i'm on a burner phone smashing mother's
building
huey we did it he's getting me the
compound being like if they
oh my god just take a beat let's figure
out the best way to do this
why what happened nothing that's just
dangerous that's all i mean you still
have your head right you're still good
you stop your head on you
[Laughter]
i just want to take our time you know do
this right that's all
uh dad dad telling me
the truth i kind of lived with it every
single day
ah stop guilting him don't lie to me
not again all right tell her the truth
i'm not oh
swear there is no god swear to me
hmm oh it's gonna be butch it's
definitely butcher it's gotta be butch
it's 100 butcher
all right
you called them i'm sorry btvs it's not
a game now
but don't you worry
daddy's home
oh no they're going to suspect he's
responsible for rainer
how did he know about it maybe it's all
over the news that she's dead
it's deputy director of the cia
oh he's so jealous
oh [ __ ] all right guys so first episode
is complete
what did everyone think i had a blast i
mean especially coming out of season one
this felt like a direct
continuation of all that momentum a
blast get it
because because things got blasted yes
you
now i get it we saw season one when it
first came out we haven't revisited it
so there's fortunately a recap at the
top of this
i remember most of the things that are
happening here i'm wondering
whoever this new girl is stormfront we
did see a trailer
and i'm not a hundred percent sure my
memory is not certainly correct i keep
wondering if she's gonna be a bad guy
like she's the way they set her up is
kind of this like
goody two-shoes they got john carlo
esposito here who uh i always love
and when he was first starting to speak
i was like he's gonna be exactly like
how he is and better call psalm breaking
bad because it seems like the kind of
role where you can be but he's not he's
definitely
bringing that same type of villainous
aspect to him but
you know much more of a corporate
presence i loved his scene that he gets
with homelander when he's talking down
to him
and there's something about it where i'm
like oh does he
have some type of power this guy that's
more than just
corporation power control over
homelander i feel like it might be a
little bit of a cop-out if he does have
superpowers because i actually love the
idea
homelander feeling a bit submissive to
him
even because of leverage yeah that kind
of abuse would not having actual
physical powers to overtake him i think
is great but there's still so much to
explore then they feel like they're
really just
like the setup that they're doing here
is that the boys themselves are
fugitives it's an interesting season too
to pick up from because sometimes with
season twos it could feel like all right
what's the tale we're telling for this
season
what's the new chapter yeah this just
feels like we're picking up
right where we left off and continuing
that exact story you know
yeah the first season was one of those
examples of a show that i watched that
really felt like
one continuous movie a lot more than
some other shows i've seen and this
definitely felt like yeah we're just
gonna continue on
with the story and it's nice to have
that level of momentum and it gets you
really excited for like i figured they
would
bring butcher in at the very end but it
like builds you up for like oh when's he
gonna come back where's that tension
because i'm kind of used to getting
access to him and yeah just to be
back around with everybody like i loved
uh
is their rapport is so great together
this is the boys in general i'm curious
to see if he's going to tell them about
what he found out about
becca and homeland or where has he been
this whole time
what what happened after that what's
with the leisure suit
maybe him homelander becca and the boy
were they they were they were
domesticated for a while
yeah polyamory i changed my mind on
soups
the best they're the best lays you've
ever had i get what my wife left me
oh my goodness sorry guys like 110
degrees in here right now
i'm not it's not even our exaggeration
is so hot so we seem a little bit like
agitated it's because like
it's still something this is a
california heat wave is really get into
it man i love the addition too of uh the
gecko guy
and the whole like s m hooker thing
selling body parts
that's fascinating and honestly what
people would do
in cinahl i feel like if i had a
superpower like that for sure i'd be
like on only fan to be like maybe a
thousand dollars buddy
i mean that's part of the beauty of this
show is they do
their best to make it feel like if
superheroes existed and how they tried
to monetize them what
would the world be like something as
small as that
is such a real list not not realistic
but a grounded edition
putting it in this world of yeah this is
what would happen
if someone had this power and if i was
the customer i totally chopped that
guy's dick off i'm just saying i would
i'm pretty surprised they killed off
that cia i'm so
shocked they killed her off one scene
she gets
one scene and i was so comfortable boom
yeah i was like oh
they still have someone on their side
nope not anymore she's gone
just like anything goes this season guys
right away
and that's a great way to start the
season off yeah is take away one of our
safeguards give us a
really huge moment to do it and then
yeah make us question where we can go
from here because it seems like even too
the starlight connection with huey
they're setting it up for more strain
this season i mean they ended the last
one being like no no trust no more
secrets and clearly that's not gonna fly
here
again i get weary of those things like i
hope that they're able to make
their drama both within the action and
interpersonally
feel nuanced in the season because i can
definitely i
wearily can get the sense that maybe
they'll just go back and forth on oh he
keeps lying but oh they want to make it
work but uh maybe they won't
oh that's boring i hope they take it
someplace bold because one of the things
that this show is great at is surprising
me with things i think characters will
or won't do the moments that really
stood out to me the
the most are stuff with like home i mean
anytime homeland is on screen he just
steals the show all you need to do is
cut to him
though i feel like it's such a stark
contrast from the first season where she
still looked kind of put together
in charge and hear it yeah like from the
first scene you're like
oh what yeah sometimes it was like
that actor looks tired character yeah
totally get him he's really great at
playing in sincerity
yeah i know he's he's fantastic at that
i mean that scene with uh the blind spot
character
he just like bashed that dude's head
he's very attractive too
who homeland homelander you think so 100
really they're like oh the more people
you are
there is something attractive about that
right like that that confidence
excuse me i just love the power that he
exudes like he puts ashley
in charge of to fill the position of
madeleine
madeleine was in charge that was her
position
and she had a leverage over him yeah and
then but that is
not the way it is now like the second
that stormfront character showed up
oh
but that's a great writing mechanism
tool to to showcase though that like
okay if ashley made this call she'd be
dead but the fact that giancarlo
giancarlo's making this call
the homelander's not gonna touch that
guy you know it's like john carlos seems
like the real big baddie of this season
in some way you know
he is the head of the corporation who's
doing all this can you remind me why
is huey so anti-butcher right now though
he seems like really
like i don't know they seem to have a
big problem with one another yeah i know
they had like that a big
i don't remember clearly they had like a
dispute at the end of last season
and they had like a falling bushes being
a total dick so
anti-butcher right now and i'm not
picking up exactly why
part of what i took from that is just
yet like yeah he seems to have abandoned
us and we haven't heard from him people
have tried calling him nobody knows
where he is and at this point you know
what we just have to
move on like we don't need him can't
just rely on him obviously because no
one knows where he is
there might be more to it or a better
reason than that but that's kind of what
i
thought jealousy too because there were
moments where he was like you're not the
leader
and then when richard comes back he kind
of gets that look of oh now i've
because he's been trying to be the
leader like now he knows he can't take
that position
and butcher's the main anti-starlight
huey you know
guy yeah kim mccoy seems like she's
going to be a character who really grows
into her own this time around
already she seems like she has more
personality yeah and she does she has
she wears makeup now
that's right she wears makeup she's not
just a dirty person
right across her face that same with
starlight taking off her makeup and
i'm just staring in the mirror like oh
i'm hideous like you look
exactly the same you look better than
when you were all dialed up for the
funeral this relationship with starlight
and huey does
make a lot of sense going off the
trajectory of last season
i don't know if it's just because i it's
been a long time since i saw season one
but i did
currently find myself like i think both
actors are doing a just a
perfectly fine job at the same time i'm
like
i don't really care as much about what's
going on with them
and i really care about everything i
care like about mother his mother's milk
getting back with his wife and daughter
kimiko frenchie i really care about them
but this whole thing with like
huey and starlight i'm not like bummed
that they're not together
which is weird because we're together i
was so endeared by it in season
one yet this time around i'm like
no you know they're not doing anything
wrong or just ah
everything else is just so much more
interesting right now yeah i just didn't
get exactly like a distinct
moment or something that clued me into
yeah where the season was going to take
that so it's kind of flailing at the
moment yeah
in like a limbo of mistrust yeah i'm at
that crossroads where like i can see
this
if they take yeah if they do something
bolder if they make a big choice with it
i can see it definitely working out this
is just the pitfall plot line that i
think shows can run into where they get
wishy-washy and they waffle on
yeah and fourth and the problem is yeah
if we don't care as much that's not
going to be as impactful so i really do
hope that they are able and like they
make they justify it obviously because
they can't
they're being watched by everybody it's
super risky for them to have any contact
but
at the same time you know i was really
rooting for them yeah in season one and
i
like to feel because the show gets so
cynical and so
pitch black dark at certain points i
like having that contrast
somewhere what do you think about the
hawkeye guy oh goodness
oh goodness what is his story i'm very
fresco
he's a friend what is with all the
fresca frosco must have paid a lot of
money for this and of course
yeah she's more than lacroix i haven't
drank a fresca since i was like
seven i think that's i mean that
storyline seems like it's gonna all be
going to support the deep storyline
maybe that's his arc this season maybe
he rehabilitates
there's something that's like it's it's
weird the first episode you get with the
deep in season one
is like man the hell with this guy screw
him i don't
like him but there's something so funny
about watching him be
so pathetic and miserable and such a
loser right you know
and he can't he can't win so much that
even like his animal powers always go
wrong
yeah he is the ultimate whomp character
i guess what i found
really impressive about for a season for
an episode one of a season two
you know a lot of times when you do a
season two you can see like
that actor looks a little different this
guy looks different the quality looks
different this looks better and other
than like the
first couple shots of homelanders i feel
like they shot this
right after they were done shooting
season one it doesn't look like they
lost
any time and i feel like from a
production standpoint that's a very
impressive touch to have on your show
because a lot of times you can tell that
difference and here i'm like this
doesn't look
any different i feel like i'm just
continuing season one yeah and i had
this hint with
uh carol's wife um
you guys i know carol is uh ross's uh
ex-girlfriend on friends ex-wife turned
lesbian is that who plays the therapist
and then uh yeah the carols
uh wife um what was her name
you know for a friend's enthusiast i'm
surprised
you're liking this yeah
the girl that ends up marrying carol
yeah yeah okay so this is in the same
universe as friends
it's in the same universe as friends
breaking bad
baby's going to come out yeah judge
dread
yeah become dreadful it really seems
like it's going to turn into
a scientology dick especially with the
clear-cut line of like
therapy is not good for you or whatever
she said therapy is destructive
scientology bottom line yeah i'm a
teacher or something
yeah i'm a teacher but it's still about
self-improvement and all these things
and finding yourself
it does seem to be a spin on scientology
specifically which you know it's never
too late to take jabs in scientology you
know there's always time
they took a lot of digs of christianity
last season yeah so now let's take digs
in scientology and
and more breast milk more breasts we've
got to get more breast milk
yeah how do you feel that scene yeah
that's the question
oh it was real breast milk definitely
dude that hormone director is amazing
yeah he's just such a captivating actor
every time he's on screen are you guys
curious about the new soup
terrorist oh yeah who flipped the photo
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah definitely curious although it's
funny like without
anything to go on except for like his
shoes and what he was wearing
how tall are you guys i was like i
almost got that
lost amid other things that are
happening in the episode but uh yeah if
they're coming on our home
turf you know it seems like it'll
definitely make a mess of things
all right guys well boys season two
episode one what'd you think
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell to get notified when our
next reaction is up oh and last but not
least
i got a shout out my homeboy eric
horstmann who i think watches this show
for my birthday he got richard spate
from supernatural and since you know
eric kripke
hired richard spake for supernatural
yeah richard's favorite supernatural
to give me a special birthday shout out
which i really appreciate a lot there is
no proper way to
describe my love and enthusiasm how much
of a support he has been in more ways
than one
specifically my way too he gave olivia
and i this beautiful blanket to honor
our uh recently passed squirrel ricky i
love you buddy
you've been absolutely amazing you're
one of the boys around here huh
you're one of the boys with the you're
kimika
you're huey
the real question though would you let
eric chop your dick off
yes gekko guy does so
i wouldn't
all right guys it's super hot thanks
[Music]
buddy
[Music]
you